(upbeat music)
- Yale Class of 2021, congratulations.
Samantha Power here.
I've been asked to keep
it short and keep it fun.
If anyone knows how to
keep it short and fun,
it's me, the author of a
700 page book on genocide.
But in all seriousness,
I hope you graduate today
with a heart full of pride,
a head full of smarts,
and a commitment to defend
dignity wherever you go.
Yours, and that of the people
in the world less fortunate than you.
COVID-19 has taken so much from us,
but it's also given us something:
a broadened sense of empathy.
This is a rare moment in time,
when everyone on planet earth
has had their lives changed together.
We all got a lesson in what
essential really means.
As you leave Yale today,
and this pandemic breaks,
I urge you not to lose that empathy.
Your concern for a world
outside of your own is the key
to living that big,
fulfilling life that you seek.
Congratulations, Yale Class of 2021.